We work at an
organization that
allows us to have a great impact
to give back to our community.
So it's a full circle of giving
where the more we give back
to our community, the
more our community's
going to give back to us.
My name is Renee Williams.
I'm a senior accountant in the
financial services department
in the non-operating funds.
When I first started and
I became an ambassador,
one of the things that
inspired me the most is I
went to a silent auction
that the sponsor project
and contracting services
team had put on.
It really inspired me
to want to do more.
Some of the events that we did
this year were three campus
pantry food drives.
We did a pledger cup, which
is where we really educated
the employees about what it
means to pledge your payroll
deductions.
We did a sock drive for the
United Way Days of Caring.
Pax hosted a pizza party as
well as a bagel and donut sale
during their last auction.
Everyone at some point
in time in their life
has either gone through a
hardship or has had a hardship,
and so I think it's important
that we come together
as a community and we
really help one another out.
If you're looking
to organize an event
and you don't really
know where to start,
I would recommend speaking
with Karla Morales, who
is the UA Cares coordinator.
She helps departments
get started,
and she has a great
source of knowledge.
Next year, we're hoping
to have a lot of fun.
I don't know what
that means yet,
but we're hoping to
have a lot of fun.
We're open suggestions, so if
anybody has any great ideas,
we would love to hear from you.